[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo son unas elecciones
particulares con la mayor participación
por correo en la historia de eeuu más de
40 millones de personas ya han empezado
a votar desde hace semanas el conteo de
las papeletas podrá tardar más de lo
esperado y dar origen a especulaciones
especialmente en el mundo de internet
donde se propagan con rapidez las
noticias falsas en esta oportunidad les
contamos qué están haciendo los gigantes
de las redes sociales para frenar los
intentos por deslegitimar el proceso
empezamos las elecciones presidenciales
de estados unidos en 2016 dejaron a los
gigantes de las redes sociales una gran
lección sus plataformas son tan
poderosas que el contenido que se mueve
en ellas puede llegar a influir en los
comicios de la primera potencia mundial
por eso este año grandes compañías como
facebook twitter youtube google y hasta
tick tock se han venido preparando para
hacer frente a la desinformación y es
que esta es una elección como ninguna
otra la emergencia es generada por el
cob y 19 hizo que en esta oportunidad el
voto por correo se disparara a niveles
nunca antes vistos en toda la historia
del país desde hace semanas millones de
estadounidenses han votado
presencialmente pero sobre todo han
enviado sus votos y algunos estados
continuarán recibiendo boletas hasta
después del 3 de noviembre último día de
las elecciones esto significa que el
ganador podría no conocerse de inmediato
un hecho que podría dar lugar a
especulaciones de fraude que ya han
venido saliendo a flote sin ningún
fundamento y que han sido alimentadas
por el propio presidente de donald trump
debido a lo anterior seguir los
resultados de las elecciones puede
convertirse en un proceso agotador
facebook anunció que sus usuarios y los
de instagram serán notificados sobre
cierres de urnas y también serán
redirigidos a sitios oficiales sobre el
proceso de conteo de votos las
plataformas además etiquetarán los
contenidos que cuestionen la legitimidad
de la elección facebook anunció el
bloqueo de nuevos anuncios políticos y
temáticos durante la última semana de
campaña y previendo que habrá quienes
intenten evadir el veto de publicaciones
falsas también limitará el reenvío
masivo de contenido a través de
messenger para evitar que material
dañino se vuelva viral la compañía
augura que las próximas semanas serán
críticas y dijo que eliminará los
llamados a una interferencia coordinada
o que inciten a llevar armas a los
lugares de votación también estarán
alerta a los llamados que utiliza el
lenguaje militarizado o que sugieran que
el objetivo es intimidar ejercer control
o mostrar poder sobre funcionarios
electorales o los votantes hace dos
meses el director de facebook mark
zuckerberg justificó estas medidas
me preocupa que con nuestra nación tan
dividida y los resultados electorales
que posiblemente demoren días o incluso
semanas en ser finalizados podría haber
un mayor riesgo de disturbios civiles en
todo el país
twitter ha venido endureciendo cada vez
más sus medidas además de instalar un
verificador de contenido a las
publicaciones que resultan engañosas
ahora usted no verá en su página de
inicio los contenidos que le gustaron a
sus contactos en lugar de solo retuitear
una información twitter le solicitará
que agregue un comentario aunque esta
opción puede ser descartada
estas modificaciones estarán habilitadas
al menos hasta el final de la última
semana electoral dado sus comentarios de
los últimos meses y semanas existe la
posibilidad de que el presidente de
donald trump rechaza los resultados de
las elecciones si éstos no les son
favorables sólo hasta hace poco aseguró
que aceptaría una transición pacífica
del poder pero dijo que antes que nada
quiere unas elecciones justas twitter
por ejemplo se ha preparado para este
escenario
etiquetar hemos los tweets que afirmen
falsamente una victoria para cualquier
candidato y eliminaremos los tweets que
fomenten la violencia o pidan a las
personas que interfieran con los
resultados de las elecciones o el buen
funcionamiento de los lugares de
votación facebook google y hasta tick
tock se han venido preparando contra la
desinformación pero preocupa que tan
exitosos podrán resultar estos esfuerzos
teniendo en cuenta que aunque las
principales plataformas están tomando
acciones también existen otros espacios
donde no hay ningún tipo de control
veamos que dicen los medios de
comunicación fox news la cadena favorita
del presidente donald trump entrevistó
al director de parla que es una red
social usada por los sectores
conservadores el ejecutivo prometió que
el contenido en su sitio no será
censurado ni editorializado antes del
día de las elecciones
la revista technology review del
instituto de tecnología de massachusetts
hizo una investigación sobre las teorías
conspirativas acerca de los comicios que
dice que los esfuerzos para socavar las
elecciones son demasiado grandes para
que facebook y twitter puedan
afrontarlos ya que es una explicación
conspirativa a largo plazo
no solo un incidente de desinformación
viral la revista 'time' consultó la
opinión de un experto que dice que si
eeuu depende de las plataformas de redes
sociales privadas para comunicar de
manera confiable los resultados de las
elecciones entonces los estadounidenses
están en apuros un artículo del portal
bloomberg dice que cualquier
consecuencia es resultado de miles de
decisiones individuales y que nosotros
como usuarios tenemos el poder de no ser
parte del problema
por último le dejamos una serie de
recomendaciones para actuar con
responsabilidad y evitar caer en las
noticias falsas primero lea la noticia
antes de compartirla segundo contraste
la información que recibe con otras
fuentes de noticias confiables si la
información está en un sitio del cual
nunca he escuchado hablar compruebe su
veracidad en un buscador como google en
caso de detectar información falsa en
redes sociales reporte la
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www france24
puntocom
[Música]